Coulson Whitehead
Colson Whitehead one of the first and
only novelists to win the Pulitzer Prize
for back-to-back Works how in the hell
did you do that
[Applause]
pretty good man
I'm kind of looking for back to back
myself
[Applause]
for his extraordinary contributions to
the American Songbook and for being the
boss
one of our greatest performers and
storytellers Bruce Springsteen's music
celebrates our triumphs heals our wounds
and gives us hope capturing the
unyielding Spirit of what it means to be
American
[Applause]
for her iconic voice as the Empress of
Seoul Gladys Knight's exceptional Talent
influenced musical genres from rhythm
and blues to gospel to pop and inspired
generations of artists captivated by her
soundtrack of a golden age in American
music
thank you
[Applause]